what's going on you guys it's your girl
nikki blades and you're now
tuned in to the beautiful women of big
moves
we love that we have our our next
favorite returning
we have two favorite okay stacy diaz is
our first favorite the og
nikki blaze is our new favorite in no
particular order
and no production she placed an order
yeah no it's okay
hierarchy stacy is our og favorite i
mean you can't
like beat the timeline wise right came
first like the firstborn favorite
how many episodes do i need to be in to
beat her
i'm coming for it i got nothing to do
and then just me and tiff over here on
the left yeah jessica
what's wrong with jeff i'm just [ __ ]
her up
i'm kidding it's because
i'm nervous tess that's our name jif
jeff ted i like tess tess that's an
actual
[Laughter]
[Music]
well i think i think i'm nervous because
we're going to start talking about
breakups in this episode
dude that's all we talk about on [ __ ] i
don't tell you i'm word vomiting right
wake up
you should just break up i really want
us to do a segment in 2021 where we have
like viewers
give us their you know their this
current relationship status
signs break up or stay together make it
work
we do need a lot of information though
to make that true okay they'll give you
all the information good solid two or
three paragraphs we'll say oh no totally
yeah are you gonna do this thing called
dear nicki oh they'll tell you yeah
oh they'll tell you somebody's gonna
have to filter through it to get to the
meat of it they'll give you all the
details trust
so we do get a lot of questions in our
dms
about how do i deal with this breakup i
think when you're going through a
breakup
um it's probably one of the hardest
things to
have your head on straight so you're
just like scrambling to try to find
something to hide the pain you're like
someone please give me the answer
how do i get over this or how do i numb
this or how do i just
i want it gone it's like a pimple you
want it out of your body
yeah well emotionally you know it hits
the same part
that you experience when you experience
the death of someone close to you yeah
so when you experience loss but the
society doesn't treat you
that way like this is a lot more
sympathetic when you're going through a
loss of a person but when you're going
through a breakup they're like can't get
over it
yeah yeah it's the same feeling it's
because it's it's kind of like
an addiction right so a lot of times
society looks down on people that have
addiction opioid addiction heroin
addiction or whatever
like i can't be like you're trash right
you feel
the same withdrawal it feels horrible
but
no one kind of really cares you know
what i hate about
the like the the double standards with
it all
if someone gets a divorce for some
reason it's you're more
sympathetic towards them than somebody
who goes through a breakup with you you
know why because your finances are
impacted
you were like messing with your [ __ ] you
spent
forty thousand dollars on a wedding and
you stood in front of all of your family
and you said forever we're gonna be
together this is now your son-in-law
this is now your daughter-in-law
now it's like kids involved it's like a
whole another mess yeah
i just i just feel bad for the regular
people who get broken up oh for sure
it's you know the regular people
you know the regular people who ain't
got husbands before they're like that's
cute
yeah they're like [ __ ] you nobody cares
about you get another boyfriend shut up
a lot of women i've been reading a lot
on the internet a lot of women are like
actually being divorced is great and i
don't want to get married again
after going through the process like
when you're out the other end it's a
long drawn-out
thing that it's not quite as shocking as
like oh i dated this guy for six months
we fell in love it was like [ __ ]
passionate as [ __ ] and now it's
blown up in my face i think to me that
feels worse
than going through a 10-year marriage
and like dragging out the divorce like
you're kind of over it
you're like whatever dude yeah it's
really it's really dope finally
traumatized by
lawyers so anytime like lawyers getting
like
money yeah that's it that's that's super
scary it's great when you see people
that
get to the point to where i i feel like
a separation
with a with a divorce and a breakup
there's kind of like a set of rules with
a divorce and
everybody knows them right there's the
process you understand
there's things you're going to have to
go through separating the assets finding
the kids
but when you break up and you you go
suddenly you could have been living
together it could be almost identical to
a marriage except the paperwork
something there's no protection and
there's no protection and there's no
there's no empathy like nobody's really
sympathizing or empathizing with that
person they're like oh well you're not
married that's kind of like
there's plenty of people do have
different um like
certain states have common law marriage
like i think in texas i think you have
to be together for like three years or
something
really short and then they consider it
like a common law in marriage
but then overall for sure you know
society we look at somebody who's been
in a relationship for seven years
and unless you know the people you're
like damn that really sucks versus
somebody who got divorced after two
years you're like
oh my god that's so devastating again do
you think about the process but
yeah the morning you know we do we do
treat breakups very dismissively um
we kind of like some people you're like
depending so depending on the person to
me
if you're a person that's going through
a breakup every other month i'm like i
kind of get over it
but if you're like you've been with your
partner for a while and
you like the whole brain yeah exactly
like jess's
breakup like with joe it's like we're
we're still friends with joe
and you know more friends than me yeah
but i'm more friends you're more friends
with she's
a win yeah he picked your side and then
i go and jake i'm like
joe i think
it was kind of the same because joe we
didn't hang out
like so um joe actually pushed me to
hang out more with jess because she's
he's like she needs more girlfriends and
so then that that's when we started like
forming the girl circle because none of
us really
hung out as a girl group before then and
i feel like
yeah joe kind of pushed that together
for jess
and then i yeah i've definitely hung out
a lot more with jess than with joe since
then so
i feel closer to i'm the winner of the
team just one okay
i want everybody listening thank you
even though i know joe way longer but i
know you win thank you
yeah um
uh don't forget you didn't forget the
hashtags that you keep
seeing no
no it was funny because people started
putting jokey because they're like yeah
because this is the whole thing
yeah the whole thing isn't good i wonder
if people know i think most people do
not but like i write the titles for jk
news
oh my god and then the episodes that are
coming out pretty soon i think i had one
uh recently it said like no it's really
happening
it's like clickbait oh central and i
swear there's times where i have no idea
what's going on and then i'll get like a
boost on my instagram and people start
writing like people were writing no
instagram and i was like what the [ __ ]
is no like why is everybody writing no
on my education i totally forgot clearly
i'm so invested into this relationship i
don't even
know how you're like it's my outfit that
bad everyone's writing no
no no no no no this photos no yeah and
then i forget
that i'm there i forget the whole thing
and i'll be like why is everybody
[ __ ] talking about joe oh my god damn
i'm hot just talk about how hot i am
yeah yeah [ __ ] joe what about me so
funny
no then it's also even more funny
because then people will be like oh jess
is so jealous but she's literally the
one writing there was some comments on
our uh
the first time you came on our show
people were like oh just hates her you
can tell oh
i saw somebody say [ __ ] where i can't
believe nikki has the audacity
to be sitting next to jessica i was like
wow first the [ __ ] off i got invited
here you invited her
here what are you talking about you like
make up some crazy [ __ ] i love it
people love to make drama stories and
it's kind of cute
it's this generation's soap opera yeah
yeah that's why it's like i forget
we're we're still popular characters i
have to not take it personally we're
real people
yeah if i didn't want her on the show
she wouldn't be on the
show i own this [ __ ] company with
other girls yeah i would have said
i would have never made it past the
first round they would have been like
who the [ __ ] is this big
yeah oh first episode they shipped up
not [ __ ] she's gone we don't want her
you're like break up [ __ ] i'm still
going through it [ __ ] you get out of
here i want
joe to be happy that's something that
you guys don't understand too so
regardless of who
comes up to him next i don't think it's
gonna be
but whoever comes up to him next like i
want him to be happy and that's
something that you guys need to [ __ ]
get through your head
yeah and when i talk [ __ ] on my
instagram about men it's not about
joe it's about the other guys that i've
been doing oh my god it didn't cross my
mind
just because i excuse you
because i know i know you and like the
fact i would never even think that but
being an audience member
yeah i guess if i try to find myself all
watching this show too like
you know me from from before when i was
on jk news or whatever being joe's vlogs
and now i'm talking [ __ ] about my i've
been dating dudes
yeah that are not joking i think it's
because people don't know what healthy
breakups look like yeah
like a lot of people think like as soon
as you guys break up you you it's world
war three the devil
right the enemy and then there's no way
that you can actually have a mature it's
a work relationship exactly yeah
yeah i did not go through healthy
breakups oh my god nope did not most
of mine were not great yeah but this one
was fine i'm impressed by the people
that
are mature enough i think again like you
get to a point where you really don't
want to be with each other
yeah and that's when most of the
breakups are
a little bit smoother like yeah we
dragged it out so long that it didn't
hurt anymore and then you both are
self-aware you know what's working for
you you know it's not
now when breakups get traumatic it's
normally
when one person wants to be in it and
the other person doesn't yeah
and so the betrayal comes in we're not
mature enough to know when to walk
not a healthy communication like being
broken up with through a text message
or whatever you're invested it's like
i've done so shocking with someone over
text message but
it was like a two month oh yeah that's
different that's different that's true
there wasn't like a real like this guy
lived with me oh yeah what do you do
well it was yeah it was the one that
cheated on me and then like so then i
found out through the girl i confronted
the girl and being like i know you don't
know me
and i'm so sorry like i don't want to be
that person but like
is there something going on because you
keep saying there's not and like i feel
like there is and she's like girl yes
there is she's like
he told me you guys were broken up and
then she made him call me
and then yeah it's always like a phone
call not a text i guess but
it wasn't i didn't get that face-to-face
like communication like hey
we need to talk what about him moving
out what was that like so he had already
moved out
um because we broke up earlier in that
year and then we got back together
within two weeks
so he found his own place it was
probably healthier mentally
but um yeah then then we got back
together
and we were already together for like
six or seven months
and that's when there's something
similar like that with my ex
because like we were together for three
years we ended up living in a
same place and then uh and then
we our lease was up for that place that
we had together and i was like i can't
[ __ ] live with you like i [ __ ]
can't
he's the one that i kept waking up and
his dick was inside me
who's the one that gave me ptsd yeah
that's the guy that gave me ptsd with
morning sex and so i was just like i
can't be with you i can't live with you
um and i kept trying to break up with
him so many times and it was just
he somehow like always had me go back i
was i think i was
heavily codependent too so that i was i
was just attached
to that and and it was really hard to
to finally completely let him go but
once we moved out at that place that
that the lease was was up actually
during that place we had broken up for a
whole month
and he moved to the other room because
of the two-bedroom apartment oh we went
to the other room i had
had the other room with isaac and there
was this time where like
he we were like still kind of friends
but like we were
broken up but we were still living
together and it was [ __ ] messy it was
really weird
but then eventually once i moved out and
got my own place
he would come over and like you can't
sleep over you can't keep any of your
[ __ ] here
um but then eventually he we ended up
like slowly
getting back together and and then
i ended up moving to a different place
still not with him and then at that
place
finally was when i was like that's it we
can't be together and if
if you somehow like try to drag me back
into this relationship i need to move to
san diego to get the [ __ ] away from you
because i was just so
scared of like i didn't trust myself to
not
be with him anymore yeah i was just so
stuck in this like toxic cycle of this
it's an addiction relationship yeah
i was in the worst i was we were so
obsessed with each other but he
could my you know the worst one he just
couldn't stop his problem he had a
problem he
loved talking to multiple women he loved
seeing me
angry he loved but it was a lot of it's
actually funny i had posted up a song
today and
it was like drew hill i love you and
it's funny because the lyrics are like i
told you to leave
but no no i don't want you to go i love
you i'm professing my love i can't live
without you you know the real
toxic [ __ ] right there and i said yo if
you grew up on any of these damn r
b songs definitely been in a toxic
relationship
because i believed that you know he
messed up and he came back but he loves
me
and he'll do anything for me and
honestly my dumb ass was in that cycle
for a long
time something that i didn't even learn
probably until
not that long ago is that when they come
back it's not
because they love you it's because you
let them come back yeah
yeah and it's not a profession of love
it does it's not a sign that you're
meant to be together it's a sign that
your standards are too low
yeah you're a mantis i i romanticize
that [ __ ]
about this because there was a song that
was stuck in my head and i was like i
have to play this song
oh yeah yeah it was jessie reyes coffin
and then eminem collabs on it and he
references his other song that's very
similar
in content um with rihanna i love the
way i love the way
yeah i love the wheel and uh and it's
it talks about that that like i'm gonna
kill myself and then that person goes
and saves you right before you jump off
the roof and then
it's like oh because they love you and
you're passionate but you can't stop
fighting
and it's like something it's just juicy
because it's like
passionate yeah but it's so toxic it's
not
enough and it shouldn't be romanticized
but i
that feeling is like ah like i remember
that feeling of just like the
just emotions i feel it here
here and certain people will bring out a
side of you that is
not supposed to come out and honestly if
you don't go through those messy
situations you don't know what your
limits are you don't know
you don't know what you're capable of
you don't know what is okay or what your
buttons are
that particular man i
was god i felt like i couldn't breathe
without him
like there's still something about to
this day we might fight each other like
nobody's comfortable if we're even in
the same
like area code we just cannot
coexist we can't deal with each other we
are not going to be friends
we're never we're never going to be
friends we're never going to be like
what's up homie
never right i think that because we're
always going to care for each other
but we're never going to be together we
can't you reach a point where you learn
what a healthy relationship
is because you just know what you don't
want to go through anymore yeah
there was a quote um mark manson who
wrote subtle art of not giving a [ __ ]
um he we follow him on instagram me and
jess and
i pulled a quote following him after you
guys yeah so he
posted he posts different things because
he writes articles and he's
really good at writing um but one of the
quotes he posted was there's a
difference between
chemistry and compatibility and the
difference between them because people
use them interchangeably
all the time and chemistry is this thing
that we're talking about where it's like
you get together the sexist [ __ ] bomb
like you guys just like
there's this heated like thing right
like don't might punch him in the back
of the head if i see him with another
person
like i yes because there's something
that just dangerous
date that's the best way to describe it
there's compatibility which is your life
values are the same
you want the same kind of future you you
kind of like
have the same view of the world you know
how to like manage
stuff together that's compatibility and
the key is trying to balance
both it's confusing though because i
always thought it was the same because
i'm like well we're compatible with our
music tapes we're compatible in bed
we're compatible with the fire that we
have for each other they're not the same
compatible is literally
take out erase the chemistry yeah are
you compatible
as if they were your friend yeah like do
you like the same
things you have the same ideas you want
to go the same places like if
you're compatible with a guy that wants
to be dan bilzerian
on a boat with a bunch of hoes that's
not your lifestyle
i'm lifestyle spilling the tea on myself
i'm not wishing dan bilzerian is not
attractive he's repulsive stop trying to
be
him you know who you are
yeah chemistry but not compatibility
yeah
you know how you know we talk a lot
about the friend zone
right like guys are like oh i got friend
zoned and yeah she doesn't want to pay
a relationship put themselves there by
the way so
i had somebody that i had dated
and then stopped dating i kind of was
like oh this isn't working i'm gonna go
i want to do whatever i want and cut it
off and after that talks the one that i
talk about the toxic relationship him
and i ended up getting back together
because we had somehow stayed friends
post us like
dating briefly it was kind of like
casual right
um we ended up getting into a
relationship and i remember
the starting of that relationship i told
him like i am not
whole i really shouldn't be in a
relationship with you we
really shouldn't get together i am
nowhere near i was a
i was a mess and i was openly a mess i
knew it
he was my little knight in shining armor
and he wanted to be there and i know
that
so many people want to help others and
be like i'm going to be there for you no
matter what no matter
no matter what you're going through i
want to be there and the the shitty part
about that is
is if you allow yourself to be in that
relationship
and you know they're with you because
you're broken
the unfortunate part is the relationship
will change as you become whole
when you're not broken anymore it's not
going to survive and and the more you
put yourself together
and it's crazy because that last
relation
my my current ex was a good guy
he is a good guy i loved his values
love his family what he stands for his
core
but something happened along the lines
of resentment towards me
for the beginning of the relationship
like i was i wasn't
all the way in it i definitely was just
a hot a hot mess
you know i hold myself accountable for a
lot of the things that didn't work out
in that relationship
but what sucked was people stay in
things that they shouldn't be in
um and holding resentment towards
somebody and then
using it when you're now the one who
cares the least in the relationship
is it's really [ __ ] up yeah resentment
is
i feel like transforms and takes over
your relationship because it won't allow
you to not view that person as
the enemy like once you have enough
resentment
the slightest little thing they do you
can twist it and be like because they're
doing that again
and it's always the slight against you
instead of just allowing them
to be and love them for who they are the
person that you fell in love with
and it's something that it takes over
slowly and you can't
you can't always catch it you got to
catch it when it's like yeah and it's
beginning phases you got to stomp that
you got to wash it out yeah yeah there
we go we're going to wash it out
with shampoo from functional function of
beauty
yes and it's customizable because
everybody's got different hair
we got some curly hairs we got some
straight hair bleached
hair some thin hairs some bleach tears
and depending on what your hair is they
have
so many different combinations of
formulas that'll fit your specific hair
needs and that's what i like the most
about them also just like custom
[ __ ] you know like give me the one
that's for me
it has my name on the bottle [ __ ] so
every bottle that you get has your name
on it it's like function mine's this
function of limo because i just thought
it was more regal to have my last name
on there
why doesn't it say green because my name
is limo i think there's a problem in
your marriage it's limo green
i have independence in my marriage it's
a partnership
not a codependency anyway
function of beauty you go on there you
take a little quiz so they're going to
ask you about your hair you're going to
fill out all the answers
as accurately as possible also your hair
goals like what do you want you want
more shine you want more volume you want
less frizz whatever that is you're gonna
put that in there too then you're gonna
pick a scent or if you don't want a
scent
no scent maybe that's more your size
your fragrance is not good for your skin
yeah
sometimes it messes with your scalp your
ph balance i don't know i'm not a
scientist
but pick a scent that you like my i love
the eucalyptus because it's just what
i'm getting next
you guys keep talking about it it's like
makes your stress dissolve
yeah it's in your scalp i don't know i
like it a lot and then you pick a color
whatever color suits you for that month
or six months it lasts a long time
that's a really big color that you like
i like the the black one but i don't
think they do it anymore they do it
seasonally yeah they might be seasonal i
have purple currently and i like that
one
and then uh yeah they also offer a new
skincare line it's the same quality and
customization you expect but now for
your skincare routine so check that out
as well
what are you waiting for you like the
lotion yeah i like the body and that's
customizable
too based on your skin needs so what are
you waiting for go to
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to take your quiz and save 20
off your first hair care order
go to functionofbeauty.com big mood to
let them know you heard it
about it from our show and to get 20 off
your hair care order that's
functionofbeauty.com
big mood yes and another shout out to
one of our favorites
doordash they supply us with our
food because you know it's actually
supposed to be lunchtime but you know
we're lazy
we i mean we're busy we're working we're
independent women
i mean busy not lazy we're making busy
money okay we don't have time to like be
running around
trying to figure out what we're gonna do
for lunch so doordash brings our food to
us
and right now you know restaurants need
as much support as you can i think a lot
of people are at home cooking but
uh neighborhood restaurants still need
to make some money there's jobs
you know yes we can order out every
restaurant we can order out every once
in a while
there's thousands of restaurants open
for delivery on doordash that need your
patronage
now more than ever support them with
doordash
ordering is easy open the doordash app
choose what you want to eat your food
will be left safely outside your door
with a contact list delivery drop-off
setting they have all kinds of national
favorite restaurants as well like
chipotle wendy's cheesecake factory
um it's not the same wendy's
[Applause]
okay
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of fifteen dollars or
more which is pretty easy to hit because
you know
i order like seven eight dollars
there's no doll hairs in your food
download the doordash app and enter code
big mood that's
five dollars off zero delivery fees on
your first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code big mood don't forget the big mood
code
you guys that's how we get credit for
sending you there yeah
don't forget that's code big mood for
five dollars off your first order with
doordash
so what was your worst breakup the one
she just went through probably oh was it
i would say the one that i went through
the most recent one
it was it was just disappointing
it wasn't as catastrophic and dramatic
as the one prior to that
the one prior to that was the young
crazy probably like
all the young ones are crazy yeah like
my first real love we were together for
a long time we
moved in together that was the first guy
i ever really got a place with i wanted
i actually wanted a family with him that
was probably the hardest part about it
yeah i wanted us to have a family
together he
made me want that and i didn't want that
initially i never really looked forward
to like a wedding i didn't really have
like a lot of boyfriends and i wasn't
allowed to date growing up so
the way i looked at relationships was
not healthy
yeah i had a relationship in high school
and we were together for like three
years but it was long distance
he like lived 30 minutes away i didn't
couldn't drive my dad never knew about
him it was a whole hidden thing
and i wasn't allowed to date so it
really made me look at relationships
completely just not in a healthy way
and i was raised to pretty much not want
to get married our family was like you
don't need to i never grew up around a
lot of successful married couples
my parents are together but not married
oh interesting
yeah so i never saw a healthy
relationship
yeah no not at all my parents are
[ __ ] nuts
yeah they're like they're crazy they're
still together but they're crazy
is it what happens when a tornado missed
the ball okay
i love you too much so walk away though
okay stop i don't know what's happening
i don't know where it's from it just
came to me
yeah but but that i don't know like
watching my parents go back and forth
that that you know it explains a lot and
why i have
i don't really break up well i don't
really do the
close the door closure i'm done walk
away my sister can cut somebody off
oh my god if my sister has broken up
with you she is ruthless she is cold she
is done
over she will not even allow you to have
the opportunity to cheat she should be
narrows
she is a capricorn she will dead that
before it gets to that point and for me
i'm like i watched the back and forth i
saw my parents stay through it all i
remember my
uh the dramatic breakup he said your
parents went through worse and they're
still together
and they love each other and when he
used my parents against me i'm like
oh this unhealthy situation was okay
yeah and even my
you know even my parents told me about
that relationship my parents
they do call it you know they'll be like
that's gonna work that's not gonna work
and my parents haven't really been a fan
of the people that i've
you know been with and the traumatic one
they saw my mom was like you know you're
dating your father right
like you know yeah you're dating your
father
and you don't want to do that you're
just like you really don't want to go
through that
and it was it was just so hard to
separate and i and we definitely dealt
with each other for years
after the breakup and then this most
recent one we don't even know how to
just end
things all the way it's still like i
remember there was a point in time where
i just was in love with the i loved who
his family
was and who he was supposed to be and as
he was changing and not being that
person that
i wanted to be with i couldn't let go
i know there was there was power shifts
in that relationship there was
i will never say that oh he ain't [ __ ]
and i just walked away like no
i believed that this person could
potentially be a great partner
he loved the idea of him more than you
loved him totally like he would be a
great father he loves kids he has a good
family i think about the things that i
missed growing up
and what i wanted and his family and he
had it but
us together no yeah
the big the biggest takeaway and it's
we're not
cordial we're still really figuring it
out i would say
with the separation we haven't been
together for a while and we're still
learning how to deal with it in our own
way
i don't hate him because i know he needs
to go through his change
and that's hard to to look at somebody
and understand why they do exactly what
they do
it you know we've talked about instagram
before on here
and he purposely does things and for me
i had to learn to control myself it's my
responsibility
to not react yeah it's his
responsibility to live his life and it's
my responsibility
to live mine and i may not react to what
he's doing now yeah or know what he's
posting it's a lot of provoking because
we're not completely cut off
from each other i'm still following you
think that you should still be
putting yourself through that exactly i
i shouldn't be so it's it's knowing and
holding yourself accountable like
girl why you want to hurt yourself today
yeah you know why am i going to put
myself through that i can't be
mad we can't be mad at each other we
shouldn't be mad at each other
uh we need to learn how to let go i
think you know
i feel like you and joe hit a point to
where you understood you guys weren't
gonna work out yeah and you guys still
have a relationship where you work
together and you can respect each other
very distant still though like you're
not talking on a normal basis right
and there's still times where him and i
speak we do
still share the dogs and do we having a
co-parent dog parent and then you know i
still talk to his family i still talk to
his mom we're still very much connected
and we don't know how to separate yet
we've been friends for so long
it was more of like the friendship when
that was gone because
our rome our romance was always i think
i was
way less romantic than he was and so on
my end and i look at the relationship i
didn't give him what he needed
so it's hard like how am i gonna keep
being mad at you
when i know i didn't do everything you
needed
and then you didn't do what i needed
yeah and we don't
know how to meet in the middle yet do
you think that like you kind of still
being
minorly entangled in that is keeping you
from like moving on
yes i don't know how i i really do still
feel attached i feel attached
and there's still there'll be times
where he'll make a comment
on something that i'm doing and i'm like
why are you trying to fight me today you
know it almost feels like
give me give me a couple days yeah i'm
still trying to learn we're still trying
to learn how to be ourselves because
we're still doing things
with each other in mind you all need to
be communicating have you thought of
like trying to go no contact for a
little while just
to like get through some of it yeah we
need you
because i think you need to build a
foundation without him first and you
can't do that if he's still
there like you're still thinking about
him yeah he's still popping up in your
feed and stuff
are the ties because if it's effective
it doesn't have to be forever but just
i feel like maybe you need like a three
or four month i
didn't relax out yeah i didn't really
date like i
haven't you know covet happen a lot of
stuff is going on and
honestly i don't even know also i'm not
looking i feel like i have to like just
put that i'm not looking
um and specifically because i'm still
fixing me
you know it's really about the self-work
yeah and
it's so cliche but it's so true like
yeah
the best way to get over a breakup or
codependency issues and stuff is to like
invest in yourself invest in like
self-love like finding things that you
really like oh [ __ ] like
you did that girl like you know like i
didn't have that i was very hard on
i've always been hard on myself i still
am but i didn't have things that i
liked about me you know and so when i i
liked him like i
put all my like energy and like love
into like
oh my god he's so cool and everything
hurts so bad when it's
yeah and then when that left is like i
don't like anything i don't like it's
just a shell
yeah i don't feel like there's nothing
where my love is not going anywhere
like it's just like i don't like any i
hate everything now
and um and then finding like things that
i could like about myself or like i like
what i do or
like around me like building on those
likes
is what creates like that self-love and
then it becomes ingrained in you where
you're like i do love myself
yeah and then you attract the partner
that like sees all that in you
and because people see what you're
putting out you know and
and even subconsciously they pick up on
it and so when you're trying to attract
a partner that's going to love you or
like have that mutual love like you need
to love yourself first
on that level you know we were we were
also discussing how the people that you
keep around you you're really a
reflection of the company you keep yeah
and i noticed that the more i started
investing into me
the more other people were like oh nikki
you're glowing you seem happy
you're like this you're like that and
especially being a part of you know this
group and being able to come on it
really
it speaks volumes for the growth because
i don't even know if i would have been
say like a couple years ago or even
while i was in that relationship i
i've noticed my growth from the
beginning of the year to even where i am
now the self-awareness and when you do
start
acknowledging your fault in things it
really makes you not hate other people
as yeah
you know i i started learning to
understand people a lot more
the more i understood myself and i do
think it's a compliment to
have a level of self-awareness that most
people
don't have it's kind of something i'm
like i got issues like i have no problem
saying i got issues am i ready to date
somebody hell no but i also know that
when i do find someone
i'm gonna have to like let them know as
well there are things that i'm working
on and
and that's will you be able to help me
with that like if i'm not all the way
whole by the time i get into my next
relationship it's going to have to be
communication forever all the way home
yeah but communicating
you know being able to say that you know
i felt like i said that in the beginning
of the relationship
and i kind of was like [ __ ] it okay
we're doing this he cares about me he
loves me
but i still for some reason i'm not
like i'm not treating him the best but
he's still with me this is weird
you know and and when people love you
when you're not really who you're
supposed to be it's kind of a mind [ __ ]
right that's why a lot of relationships
people change
and they change through it and they
change after and they change in another
relationship
because we're so influenced by who we're
around
yeah that's why the whole thing about
like getting married when you're
young like don't do that because it's
not that people are saying your love is
fake
or that like you're you guys don't know
what you're
getting into it's just that you grow so
much
from when you're 20 or like 20 20
early 20s to when you're early 30s and
when you're thinking about
like marriage is supposed to you know be
your lifelong
partner you don't know if that partner
is going to be the same partner
10 years from now and so that's what's
really hard to measure
when you get married so young and i do
think that that contributes to
like a high divorce rate and all that
stuff like people who get married
um i think the age i remember for women
i remember for men but for women it was
like at 28
is like the sweet spot like a good age
for you to
get married because by that age you
already know yourself well enough and
your brain doesn't fully develop until
you're 25.
so the dopest thing i saw is normal lies
finding love later in life yeah like if
you
find the love of your life at 50 and
y'all stay together for 30 years
you're only eight you know like normal
lies
relationships not needing to happen at
don't force them because
timelines yeah yeah and that's why
breakups feel so traumatic i think we
have a level of expectation that we
place upon ourselves because
oh so-and-so is married and so-and-so
has kids man there was
i remember at 27 27 28
i became the last person in my family to
not have a baby wow
not have a baby you know going up and
down in my relationships figuring out my
career
but it was something that it sucked
because you base your normal off of
what's going on around yeah so if you're
like oh i'm lacking here when everyone
around you
i resented my ex even though i was in
another relationship and we were still
figuring it out i remember
hating my ex when i became the last one
and i was like
i had you and i just remember this this
conversation
with myself that i was having with to
him and i used to have to write
um if you're going through a like a
really hard breakup and you're trying to
cut communication
i do suggest writing out the
conversations that you want to have
to get it out of your body yeah write it
out um throw it away get rid of the [ __ ]
just you know get rid of it but i
remember
hating him because
i wanted that with him right and it
that particular person made it so
difficult for me to let go of him
because i was weak and he always prayed
on that and we did the stupid back and
forth and you know like we could just
feel each other thinking yeah but i
remember the day
and i was just livid and there were
times up until i want to say recently
that i felt that both of them
you know um they they played their part
you know when when my last relationship
didn't come through i'm like
bro i gave up this this and this and now
you don't wanna
you don't want it i'm at home i'm not
out in the streets i got a job job
you know i i'm putting myself in a
position to have a family to have a life
and
now now you want to go find yourself i
remember being mad when that moment
happened
and it was like i don't want to be
later in life trying to figure out if i
want to have a family
but as time goes by and you start
understanding that
i can't force nobody to be with me if
that if we're not supposed to be
together we're not and he needs to find
himself because what good is he
to me if he's not whole because i
remember when
i wasn't whole right so it it
hurt because you feel like you want to
blame someone
but you know you really can't and i
think the moment that you
don't place the blame elsewhere you you
start looking at the other opportunities
that are around you
like dealing with a breakup sucks but if
you continue to hate that person they
have
all the power over you well you're just
losing yourself
like you're you're wasting time and uh
you could be wasting time
doing other things yeah like playing
buzzfeed
best fiends is a mobile puzzle game
which i absolutely love i've been
playing for many many
years you guys hear me say this all the
time but it's the truth
i haven't got gina to start playing uh
but yeah so best fiends it's this really
cute mobile puzzle game where you
collect these different fiends
and each fiend has like a kind of like
power that you can use
strategically use with the other fiends
in order to defeat the slugs
and you can go up to like infinity
number of levels because they're
constantly updating the app
they have different events different
challenges all the time
and trust me you'll never be bored with
best fiends
so you can download best fiends for free
today on the apple app store or google
play
that's friends without the our best
fiends
dude i actually got addicted to the
specific
mobile game when i was going through
that
crazy breakup when i just couldn't stop
crying but then
i had to like focus on work so i had to
have something that took my brain off of
the relationship so i got addicted to
this
mobile game and the sound of it still
like the sound effects
sometimes i hear it from someone else
playing it and it
brings me back to that moment like all
the emotions start flooding back
like from just the noises
i hate the numbing part post-breakup
yeah i hate the necessary yeah
it's necessary it's like a it's like a
stress reaction
like it's too too much to deal with yeah
we talked about music
how don't always listen to music because
the fear of being triggered yeah you
know
like i connect so many feelings with men
with the music that i'm listening to
at the time like if i discover a new
song i have a whole new playlist i'm
dating a whole new guy that whole
playlist is [ __ ] when we break up yes
it takes me a long time to get back to
that playlist any of those songs even
the artists themselves in general
that's true yeah lana del rey's first
album
is that for me luckily she changed up
her vibe like throughout the rest of her
album so i get to listen to her
i i think it's ha it's really a happy
moment when you
catch yourself just listening to music
and not feeling as much
it doesn't hurt anymore it doesn't hurt
or like watching shows
i didn't put up a tv in my apartment
when i moved for
uh for a long time so when we when we
separated
while we were going through all of it i
i actually moved out we were living
together and i moved out i got my own
place and
the biggest fight was he didn't come
with me
he didn't come the abandonment
that you feel even though you left we
didn't break up i
moved but a lot of it was like we need
to move out of where we're
at we shouldn't be here anymore what's
our goals what's our plans and
and he was out this is when he was out i
see you know he was
clearly showing signs that this wasn't
gonna happen
and i remember i wasn't able to watch tv
i caught myself being very addicted to
social media becoming obsessed with
certain things
gaming i i'm i constantly am playing
something i'm like always playing
something
and then i started channeling that into
working out again and reading
and just like the self-growth portion of
it but
it was anything that made me think of
him
was like no i don't need a damn
playstation
i'm not going to play games i'm not
going to do this oh because that's what
so-and-so did all the time and
it was like the purging process it
sounds petty
but everybody needs to do their own sort
of purging process
yeah i find myself listening to a lot of
like the
the last thing that i went through that
kind of threw me off for a little while
i
i was listening to a lot of podcasts
like a lot of very just boring stuff
like not emotional
or if it was about emotions it was like
how to control your emotions like very
stoic
like stoicism is like a thing that that
comes in and out of my life like when
i'm
hitting like the worst part of my life
like that that's
like the whole like um the the amor
fatih comes from that it's like
love your fate or whatever so you just
kind of it's like you just deal with
like
bad [ __ ] and you it's just like a way to
help you deal with it
i kind of wanted to do a whole episode
on that later maybe we can because
um it's not something that i think about
on a daily basis and i'm not sure it's
healthy to always
carry a stoic mindset but i think it can
really help you when you're going
through the worst of
of life yeah i was actually reading
because i read
a lot of investing books these days yeah
and like some top investors
um take a stoic philosophy because you
know like during the
the crash like the of 2008 when
everybody
just felt so [ __ ] the ones that were
more
of a stoicism philosophy like made it
through the crash
because it's like okay this could be
good it's just a part of why you reacted
to it yeah
yeah learning how to control your
reactions too i think as going through a
breakup you learn a lot about yourself
like who
are you how do you react to rejection
were you able to walk away i think a lot
of people
point fingers at the person that walks
away a lot and blames them
because of the hurt but we need to
acknowledge the fact that they were
bold enough and strong enough in
themselves
to not stay in something that wasn't
going to work
instead of dragging it out and is your
reaction really about losing the
relationship or is it just like an ego
thing because it wasn't your idea first
totally right and sometimes
we choose the victim role there are
plenty of people get more sympathy
yeah there are plenty of times where
people are like i don't want to i don't
want to be the villain in this no they
broke up with me
uh there but there's nothing more
annoying than the person that runs
around saying i broke up with so and so
first off
if you have to brag about breaking up
with somebody you should get punched in
the back
like you should get punched square in
the mouth because you're a dick whether
you're a girl or a guy
like well i was that brings me to what i
wanted to talk about which was
i've never been broken up with so i
actually don't know what that
can't relate i really can't relate no no
but like without
being a dick though like i do relate to
the part about
not knowing how to deal with the breakup
even though i was the one that walked
away because yeah in my last
breakup i actually had girlfriend sleep
over my house because i was just so
like i i was like trembling because i
didn't want to be alone
even though he wasn't living with me but
just the fact that we
i wasn't with someone and i had been
with someone
ever since i was 16 like literally only
two months out of my life i've been
single and
in those two months it was just really
scary
and i didn't know how to and then that's
what ended up leading me to jump right
into another relationship and then the
next one and like i never gave myself
time
to grow and know myself and understand
like who i even am and then it didn't
happen until
in the middle of my marriage that's when
i finally got to discover like what the
[ __ ] is going on because i never
actually like
like you know looked at my own
reflection and see like what is it that
i'm actually dealing with here
and i just like i was so quick to to
distract myself from the the loss
of that person in my life to go ahead
and get into something really quickly
with someone else so
people want the easiest solution for
their pain
and and that's all it does is prolong
the pain
so i don't know like when when someone's
coming at me like
in my dms right i get a lot of them like
what do i do like we just broke up and i
feel like [ __ ]
like you know like you you know what
they're saying right you can imagine
what they're saying
and really all i can say is like your
brain is tricking you right now
yeah like it's not real even though you
think it's real it's all
your perception of how bad this is i
mean i'm not talking about if you're an
abuse or whatever but i'm just talking
about the fact that you're alone
is not as bad as as it feels like the
emptiness is is a perception
um and there's so much stuff that you
can do to fix it but a lot of times like
you just have to get through the time
and not jump into something else and
it's like you have to do the work you
have to write out
what you think went wrong you have to
write out what you think went right
what you appreciate about you write out
what you want next time you have to
really say your goodbyes too don't
think it's gonna work out like it's it
could but the thing you need to do is
is set yourself up that it's not going
to you need to get healthy like it's not
going to work out like
that's the only way that it could work
out even if it does most of the times
getting back together the next is a bad
idea
and closure is overrated yeah you don't
need it doesn't
ever really happen until you decide it
you give yourself a closure i always try
to decide i always try to chase the man
down to be like
give me the clothes i but i think what
we want is not really the clothes we're
back together we i know we just want you
to tell me
we're just trying to figure out like oh
is there something that i can
fix to make this work like you don't
need that closure it's not helpful yeah
going back to tiffany you know to tiff
about
leaving we i don't think a lot of people
take into consideration
the feelings of the person that walks
away
they they you know a lot of the times
you're the bad guy you
left the relationship but you said it
right there
you're going through a loss as well
right it was it
it's never easy to leave somebody people
don't intend to just
be an [ __ ] and i really don't like
that we
shame people walking out of
relationships that aren't working
some things should be the opposite right
they didn't
drag you along if you're in a
relationship and you're waiting for
somebody to break up with you
what does that say about you you know
really start looking at are you the good
guy that you really
are are you just looking for people to
make them
the bad guy because you didn't have the
balls to walk away
and if you don't want to be in a
relationship
and you can say this isn't for me don't
let nobody shame you
don't don't let nobody shame you because
you knew that that wasn't right for you
everybody's the good guy in their own
mind you know we don't allow ourselves
to be
selfish enough and it's such a honestly
everything that you're saying right now
it like
gave me flashbacks of um with my
most recent ex the guy i keep talking
about in this episode
his parents came down on me hard when i
was trying to leave him because
he was like i i had my son but he wasn't
the father of my son and so they were
like what about your son like
your son's going to get to know all
these men and and his life
and like i feel bad for your kids
you're going gonna guilt-trip me into
staying with you that ain't gonna make
you wanna stay with you right
make you my in-laws people are not good
people no
yeah that was like the most hurtful
thing though because i really loved his
parents and i respected his parents so
much and then like
i went over to their house to say
goodbye to them because i was just like
hey
like i respect you guys i want to at
least like you should say
thank you for them saying that then
because that that makes me want to just
break it off
like whereas before you would have been
like oh i missed them
i had no my mom was there with me too it
was so sweet she was like holding my
hand she was like you know what mika
that's a good thing you're leaving this
family yeah yeah
i had one x family my my parents were
like
we all about to fight like the whole
both families are about to fight and
then
this last one i love i love my ex's
family that's always going to be your
family same i love joe's family yeah
for sure always like mamadina like
one of the most important like special
people i think that i
was so blessed to have them come into my
life because they showed me what
a healthy relationship looks like my
ex's parents have been together for 30
plus years and it's funny because my
parents are together and his parents
were together
different but his parents and his family
they showed me what i wanted and it's so
crazy because when we were going through
our breakup i remember his mom at one
point going
girl you need you need to go
leave to leave him was one of those like
not kicking me out but going this ain't
working right now
he's not ready he's not ready don't keep
hurting yourself i remember
me packing because we lived with this
family like i loved his family
that was they helped they [ __ ] they
helped raise me they helped you know put
me into the position that i am
now the love that they gave like i will
always care for them
and always care for him in the sense of
i know you got good like you're going to
be a good person one day
and you're still working on things and i
get it but
man when we did the back and forth thing
like his family stayed out of it
to be real his family was very neutral
like
everybody if i wanted to still come over
and see the dogs and to this day like
there's never going to be a problem they
don't talk bad we don't talk about
you know bad about anything and it's
just like care but there's so many other
families
that are evil that will that are just if
they're
toxic and they don't know like that
that's
i mean that's why a lot of these
relationships is cyclical it's
generational
people don't understand how love is
supposed to work and that's why we find
ourselves in these positions
i had an ex that was a drug addict and
his mom was like
texting me months later after the
breakup like he loves you
you know can you stay with him blah blah
and i'm like you can't [ __ ] you
you're trying to pull out this [ __ ]
getting your mom to ask me to be with
you
like it's at that point too i was just
like ew yeah yeah
come on yeah that's weird yeah [ __ ]
like woman's a woman you want me to be
with a drug addict your drug addict son
really
you're gonna guilt-trip me about that
there's something so amazing about the
moms out there that
know when their son ain't [ __ ] yeah like
that acknowledgement
[ __ ] yeah no when you're no car knowing
your
daughter ain't [ __ ] man if you got an
ain't [ __ ] ass
kid yes and you know there might have
been a time when i probably ain't [ __ ]
ass
you know what i mean like listen i
wasn't always the you know
i was an ancient [ __ ] i was in a you
know i definitely had my moments of
dough you don't want to be with me like
that was a mess but my parents would be
the first one to be like
yeah you don't want to be with her right
now like come back come back let her
figure it out
my my parents are very brutally honest
with that but
it's amazing when parents do their best
to raise
good humans and they acknowledge that it
may not be now
there's nothing more beautiful than a
relationship that doesn't work out and
the parents are able to say like
we're still gonna care about you i do
love my son and just to let you know
like
you're we love art we love him
we're not gonna talk smack about you and
you're always you know we we think
highly of you
but realistically like wish you nothing
but the best
uh you know you're a great person to
this day like my ex's mom is like
she's in on all the work that i do and
she just thinks that it's dope that's
awesome yeah
they genuine they genuinely just support
and because they're good
people and they know that when
like my parents would probably do the
same i'm like if we facetime and it's
like somebody's birthday you know it's
just like saying hi
because there's just respect with my
son's
father's uh family that's exactly the
kind of relationship we have too like
every time i show up and i give his mom
like a big old hug and kiss and she's
always telling me like oh me nina like
she freaking loves me and i'm yeah i
love you too
i always wonder so is it um how do
like how does casey feel about that is
it cool oh casey's like
the last person on earth to ever trip
about anything like that yeah he's super
stupid
yeah he's he's at the top of the list
yeah he's not
ever i mean like i said before we
literally have isaac's dad
we invite him into our living room we
sit around for four hours talking about
like literally anything it's like
casey's like so not that's jealous
casey does have a good like chill
personality with that stuff
yeah cause i i've never been in that
situation but i guess in the back of my
mind i would think like
um if i'm like attached to my ex's
family like if and a new person comes in
maybe their family is not good my so
like
i have two older sisters so i have two
older sisters from on
from my mom and their dad so uncle
you know i called i called my sister's
dad uncle that's just hawaiian style you
know uncle tino yeah
and my like when my dad and mom got
together
my dad knew about my mom's you know my
my two sisters and
knew uncle tino and they somehow figured
it out and my dad was like do you two
you do you want to be together it was
like no okay we family
like i would go and stay with my mom
like
they pretty much raised my mom my you
know my uncle's family
you know pretty much raised her so when
i would go back home with my dad we
would go stay with her
essentially her ex's family yeah that
was our family like to the day that my
you know to the day that uncle tino
passed away
it was like no that that's uncle when i
come home that's family like even his
daughters
were my sisters and it was one of those
things because when you know
the person that you're with don't want
the person they were with yeah
and that level of security and maturity
that you can have i mean it takes a lot
but also that's you you can't
first off you confident as hell and then
second of all you're just secure
and i think that the goal is if a
relationship doesn't work and you have
kids
that you can be secure enough to know
you guys can co-parent or
you know understand that you walked away
and it was all you can do
and that's it and you know that you guys
aren't good for each other it's really
once you know what you're worth yeah and
when you know that somebody's not
compatible or your beliefs
religion finances um i mean
[ __ ] people argue about the craziest
things opposites can attract and
sometimes people that are exactly the
same
work but ultimately if the relationship
isn't going to go further and you just
keep trying to make something
fit that isn't you just hurt yourself
yeah we have to stop that
that reminds me too like you know
breaking up with them you're like also
losing their family in some cases
but also like friendships that's that's
one of the hardest parts about breaking
up to me is if your friend groups were
too merged
you know and like they feel like they
have to pick sides
and it's like man i really liked a lot
of his friends you know
yeah we share mutual we my ex and i
share we do
for sure but yeah but i mean the ones
that were supposed to
stay in my life on a close level did and
the ones that
really were more of his friends are more
of his and it's okay like i mean
there's certain people like david is so
much closer to joe than he is to me and
i'm like i [ __ ] love david i love him
from afar we don't hang out every day
because that would be
yeah you know but like and then but you
guys like we can all
meet up for a christmas party or
whatever and it's fine like yeah but
it's like
i don't want people to be afraid to
break up because they're like oh
totally he's gonna ruin everything like
that's not a reason like it things will
fall into place and it'll make sense
and don't be that friend that's like oh
i really miss you guys together oh
yeah that sucks that sucks that's so
sweet i miss all of us spending time
together [ __ ] me too
why you think that we're struggling
right now i miss the [ __ ] too
but it is you know
and it's crazy when you really look at
everything else
fits except you two yeah
yeah you can build a life with someone
and it just be an amazing life but when
it's you too
and the doors close and it doesn't work
you know there's so many people invested
and involved and i can only imagine like
i kept my relationship
as as low-key as possible as far as
social media goes yeah
people that knew they knew we were never
hidden in public but
online it wasn't for the world i have my
own
things that i'm going through so we even
thought about that but for me
i knew that if we don't have a happy
home
anything can make it crumble and
i am so thankful that i've been able to
essentially mourn and figure my [ __ ] out
without everybody in my
business it's so good to recognize that
and be able
to let it go earlier because i feel like
people justify this a lot too where
they're like
well i've already spent five years or
six years like
and i know it's like i know there's
something wrong like when the doors
close
we are not good but i already spent so
much time
that i don't want to start over again
yeah you know and that's not healthy
at all it's a fallacy of thinking it is
in business we learn is called a sunken
cost
you can never take a sunken cost into
account with deciding what you're going
to do with things
with investments if you keep putting
money into a business
and the business keeps [ __ ] losing
money stop putting money into the
business
yeah i love that everybody figure like
has their own way of explaining
like the analogies yeah their analogies
you know business and financing works i
use sports a lot
yeah yeah yeah i use sports a lot and
and it's really cool that everybody you
just have to find what
connects you don't want to stay in
garbage time
for the rest of your life like garbage
time is like when the other team already
won and you're just like sports related
so i laughed like i have no idea what
that is
oh if you play fantasy like you kind of
like garbage time if your team is losing
because then like your fantasy players
can make up some points but anyway
it's when like so let's say my team's
playing another team
and like they won by a landslide well
now we have like our second tier players
playing because like
it's garbage time we're not gonna win
anyway like keep
your start yeah but there's still time
on the clock and you're still in the
game and we're still in the game and
yeah
you should try but like you're not going
to win
it's not worth somebody breaking your
ankle we need to keep running right
right okay i gotcha and while you're
going through the motions yeah and while
you're going through your
own breakups figure out what connects
like what you connect with you know
there are going to be times where
you know there are people that are
definitely identifying with tiff right
now that are going like
everybody looked at me like i was a bad
guy you know i was hurting too
nobody cared about how i felt and they
can really
take away from what you said like you
you made your mistakes but you
you could have done it completely
different but they're also not alone and
there's going to be people that
can look at all of us or find other
people on the internet or in books it's
really about digging into
what you can connect with and find your
way some people
go into fitness also some people get
into their health some people get into
financing
you know one of the worst things you can
do is to get into another relationship
yeah don't
understand that on yourself once again
like all those other things are
self-related
like your health your finances your yeah
it's okay to be selfish your growth is
important
we look at being selfish as such a
negative thing but there's nothing
more selfish than getting into a
relationship and giving somebody half of
you
that's true yeah oh that's a good quote
to end on
we could talk about this forever too i
love having you on the show
thanks for being here um also everybody
go
follow her everywhere buy her merch
nikki blades everywhere and then nikki
street eats
yep go check it out um also subscribe to
us and
you know like favorite do all that stuff
share it share with your friends if you
get anything from our show it really
helps us out to like
spread the love and help other people
that if you know a friend that's going
through a breakup maybe they need to
hear this right now
pass it along um if there's anything you
want us to touch on
leave it in the comments and maybe we'll
get to it later
thanks guys thank you you guys have been
listening to big moves
thank you everybody for tuning in